expendables 3 now the first one was
directed by Stallone himself the second
one by simon west from Conair fame the
third one is directed by a new guy named
Patrick Hughes and it's pg-13 too many
fans dismay the summation of this plot
is that an old rival Mel Gibson -
Stallone shows up and these guys created
the Expendables together back in the day
they used to be buddies they're not
anymore they hate each other
and Stallone is getting older he's
getting worried about his partner so he
decides to go out on his own with a
whole bunch of newer young guys to try
to take out Mel Gibson because he wants
his older buddies to survive I guess and
he wants to kill the younger people
first makes sense right no I'm not one
to automatically hate on a film and a
franchise that's usually rated R simply
because it's pg-13 there has been a film
in the past that I thought did it not
too bad actually
die hard 4 is not the best die hard but
it was still pretty badass and I had a
lot of good stunts and certainly it was
better than die hard 5 so in my opinion
it can be done if certain things are
handled correctly however in the
Expendables 3 it's unfortunately not
know I am a humongous fan of action
movies I've loved action movies my whole
life I love Arnold Schwarzenegger
Sylvester Stallone all these guys I
really enjoy watching these guys kick
ass my problem with this movie is that
these guys are just playing parodies of
themselves they're very self-aware which
is kind of cool and I understand they're
trying to go for a more silly vibe but
in the 80s when Arnold said things like
you know I'll be back and run and get to
the top like a dick what he said those
things he actually meant it he really
meant that line he wasn't trying to be
funny or silly but now when he runs in
bursts in a room and goes I gotta get
the job like it's just he's just joking
he's making fun of himself and I don't
really like that as much it kind of
takes the fun away from it even though I
think they think they're adding fun to
it I like when they just play a
character when they're not just playing
a parody of who they actually are as
actors or performers like in the second
one in Bruce Willis just goes I'll be
back
you've been back enough and then
Arnold's like yippie-ki-yay I'm like oh
my gosh did you guys just happen to
watch die hard and terminator off-camera
and now you're just gonna quote your
lines it's just I don't like how these
comes through that that being said there
is a good ass
this movie in fact an extremely good
aspect to this movie there's two of them
in my opinion for one this movie
actually does take a little bit more
time with its characters some people may
call that slow there's a little bit of
build-up to some of the characters
though they actually do give an
opportunity for some character
development in this movie which is
something I did really like but
hands-down the best part of this movie
is the villain played by Mel Gibson and
a lot of that is due to the fact that
when you take an actor at his level and
you put him in with you know
bodybuilders and wrestlers and Stallone
he's gonna look pretty damn good and my
god he was really good in this movie and
I mean he was by far the series best
villain there is a truly great scene in
this film in a truck in which Gibson
explains what he is the way he is
I thought the scene was riveting I
really wish the rest of the film was
like that and that one scene gave us
like a little hint at what these
Expendables films could really be if
they actually did try to make really
good films and not just parodies or
jokes of their former selves now how's
the pg-13 action some of it is kind of
awful you can really tell that a lot of
this movie has been chopped and edited
to because there's a lot of shots
that just seem like they're there for a
split second where you see some guy fall
down you feel like they just completely
cut out the first second that was a
blood you know explosion out of his
chest or whatever there's cut that out
and I was on the ground a lot of the
stuff that looks like it was blood seems
to have been digitally altered to look
like dust or mist and that's one of my
biggest complaints with this movie is
that it looks like the entire film was
actually shot to be rated R but now
there's all this CGI patchwork
everywhere to kind of cover up the
things that would make it rated R and
Tony abend Aris in this film is on a
level of oh my gosh he might be Jar Jar
Binks I know he might be funny I think
it's a 50/50 split whether you're gonna
go to this movie and think Antonio
Banderas is annoying as hell or if
you're gonna like him I've always liked
Antonio Banderas but in this film he
kind of rides that fence where you just
if he falls one way he's officially the
Jar Jar Binks of this movie Harrison
Ford I think is a very good replacement
over what Bruce Willis was giving to the
movie because Harrison Ford actually
looks like he's actually giving somewhat
of a performance in this film so that's
pretty cool but for the most part this
film just seems like an attempt to
finally make some money by making it
pg-13 and by sidelining some of the
characters and focusing more on other
characters that we don't really care
about it kind of ruined the movie as
well but they need to stop doing these
parody things if you got to make a good
Expendables movie just take these P
we'll show a legitimate character and
make it interesting don't just make a
whole bunch of jokes from your former
careers I'm gonna give the Expendables 3
a/c it's an entertaining film at times
however it is also a boring film at
times with a very good villain
a few good action sequences but for the
most part you can just tell that a lot
of it's been glossed over by CGI which
is very very unfortunate guys if you do
see Expendables 3 let me know what you
thought of it below and as always thank
you so much for watching guys
also my interviews are up with Sean Bean
Morris Chestnut and Ali Larter from the
show legends they're all on my channel I
was nervous as hell but I did my best to
maintain some professionalism I hope you
guys do check out those interviews the
links are in the description of this
video below thank you so much as always
for watching guys and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
min heist